So, with the way formulas work, and
how they can grab fields off related objects.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Unfortunately, you can't grab the user's email.
>> Okay.
>> But, that's only from this pick list. Instead of using
the, run this rule for criteria met, change that pick list to,
if the formula evaluates to true. And this'll be another place
that we can create a formula, in order to add some logic.
>> I've seen this before.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool. So if the following formula evaluates to true,
should I go to user?
>> So we want to still go in maitenence ticket.
>> Okay.
>> But we can treverse through that technician field.
>> Oh cool.
>> In order to grab fields off of the technician.
>> Technician, nice. Okay. So this is the
field that represents the email address of the technician.
>> Exactly.
>> And how do I check to see if it exists or not?
>> So, we can first add an if statement like we had before.
>> Okay.
>> So paste that technician email.
>> I'm going to do sum logical test with technician email.
>> This is another one of those. There's a
fancy little method out there for checking if it's null.
>> Okay.
>> So, you can actually see it right there on the right, is null.
>> Is null.
>> But I want technician email in this place where it says expression.
>> Exactly.
>> So I'm going to cut and paste. Value if true, value if false.
>> So, we can just those parameters manually. We can
put, if the value is true, set it to true,
if it's false, set it to false. And so, if
this if statement evaluates to true, then the workflow will run.
>> and then the formula, okay, the formula value is true.